.
THERE'S INCREASING CONFIDENCE IT
WILL WORK WITH THE NEW VARIANT.
>>> THE UK SUCCESSFUL VACCINE
ROLL OUT FACED ANOTHER MAJOR
CHALLENGE.
THIS ONE NORTH OF SCOTLAND.
HEALTH WORKERS HAD TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO GET SHOTS INTO THE ARMS
OF FPEOPLE WHO LIVE ON FAIR
AISLES.
PHIL BLACK TRAVELED WITH A NUS
ON A VISIT.
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT HE FOUND.
>> Reporter: WHERE THE ATLANTIC
OCEAN MEETS THE NORTH SEA, THE
WEATHER IS OFTEN DRAMATIC.
ALWAYS CHANGING.
IT ROLLS OVER SHET LILAND.
IN THIS REMOTE, BEAUTIFUL PLACE,
THE LANDSCAPE FEELS RAW AND
POWERFUL.
THESE GUSTY HILLS ARE KNOWN FOR
THEIR SHORT, OFTEN FEISTY
PONIES.
THESE WATERS ARE SHARED WITH
APEX PREDATORS.
WELL INTO SPRING AN ARCTIC BLAST
CAN BLANKET EVERYTHING,
GROUNDING AIRCRAFT AND DELAYING
A POTENTIALLY LIFE SAVING
MISSION.
ON THE SHETLAND ISLANDS, THE
WEATHER GOVRPS ALL, INCLUDING
EFFORTS TO ROLL OUT THE
CORONAVIRUS VACCINE.
EVENTUALLY THE SKY IS CLEAR AND
AN OPERATION THE LAUNCHED TO
PROTECT ONE OF THE UK'S MOST
ISOLATED COMMUNITIES FROM THE
REGION'S ONLY HOSPITAL, THE
DOSES ARE DISPATCHED TO THE
AIRFIELD AND ESCORTED BY NURSE
MARGARET COOPER.
HER JOB IS TO DISTRICT THE
VACCINE ON AN EXTRAORDINARY
PLACE.
FAIR ISLE.
A TINY WEDGE OF LAND SURROUNDED
BY OPEN OCEAN.
STEEP CLIFF, SLOPING FIELDS,
MORE THAN A FEW SHEEP AND THAT'S
IT.
PEOPLE LIVE HERE.
JUST 45 PEOPLE.
SOON WE SEE THEM STRIDING OUT,
CONVERGING ON THE SMALL BUILDING
USED ADD A MEDICAL OFFICE.
THAT'S WHERE MARGARET COOPER
GETS TO WORK.
>> YOU COME HAVE A SEAT.
A STRONG MIX OF JOLLY WARMth.
>> ALL THE BETTER.
>> Reporter: AND NO NONSENSE
EFFICIENCY.
>> THERE WE GO.
THAT'S YOU.
>> Reporter: THE RESIDENTS ARE
GRATEFUL.
>> HOW ARE YOU FEELING TODAY?
>> THE SUN IS SHINING.
AFTER A WEEK OF SNOW WE HAVE THE
SECOND VACCINES.
PRETTY GOOD.
>> Reporter: UNLIKE THE REST OF
THE UK, EVERY ONE HERE IS
GETTING VACCINATED AT THE SAME
TIME REGARDLESS OF AGE.
>> VERY HAPPY TO HAVE HAD THE
SECOND JAB AND VERY PRIVILEGED
BECAUSE IN SPITE MY GRAY LAIR,
I'M NOT THAT OLD.
>> Reporter: FOR THE OBVIOUS
REASONS, LIFE HERE IS ISOLATING
BUT ESPECIALLY DURING THE
PANDEMIC.
FOR MORE THAN A YEAR, FAIR ISLE
HAS STAYED LARGELY CLOSED OFF TO
THE WORLD.
EVEN HERE THERE'S A SPFEAR OF T
VI
VIRUS.
>> IF IT DID COME HERE, IT COULD
SPREAD LIKE WILDFIRE.
>> Reporter: JIMMY SPENT MOST OF
HIS 77 YEARS ON THE ISLAND SFLP
IT'S OPINION VERY QUIET.
I WAS A CHILD GROWING UP HERE.
THERE'S TOURISM AND PEOPLE
COMING BUT IT'S BEEN VERY QUIET.
>> Reporter: GETTING THE DOSES
HERE WAS CHALLENGING BUT
INJECTED THEM INTO ARMS ONLY
TAKES A FEW HOURS.
A SMALL FRAGILE, REMOTE
COMMUNITY WITH LIMITED MEDICAL
FACILITIES NOW HAS SOME PEACE OF
MIND.
TOMMY IS ONE OF THE LAST.
HE MOVED HERE FROM UPSTATE NEW
YORK 15 YEARS AGO.
>> THERE'S PEOPLE ALL OVER THE
WORLD WHO SPAETLY WANT THIS
VACCINE.
HERE WE ARE AND YOU'VE GOT IT.
>> I THINK IT'S IMPRESSIVE
BECAUSE I THOUGHT IT WOULD BE
THE LAST PLACE TO GET A THE
VACCINE.
>> Reporter: IT'S A RARE
PANDEMIC SUCCESS STORY.
IT'S ABOUT MORE THAN SECURING
ENOUGH DOSES.
IT'S AN ACHIEVEMENT BUILT
THROUGH THE ORGANIZATIONAL POWER
OF A NATIONAL HEALTH SERVICE
COMBINED WITH THE RELATIONSHIP,
EXPERIENCE OF LOCAL STAFF.
M
MARGARET COOPER SAID IT'S THE
PROUDEST CHAPTER OF HER 50-YEAR
NURSING CAREER.
>> IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO BE PART
OF THE VACCINATION PROGRAM AND
FEEL THAT YOU ARE CONTRIBUTING.
>> Reporter: A CRUCIAL
CONTRIBUTION TO AN UNPRECEDENTED
OPERATION THAT'S SAVING LIVES
AND RESTORING FREEDOMS
EVERYWHERE IN THE UNITED
KINGDOM.
PHIL